I call this network concepts we really
should have a broad scheme of what we're
looking at today these are the kinds of
things which we mostly try not to think
about even though we use networks these
things are things that are people like
me people like mr. Whitmer mrs. Ryan
people who oversee networks they have to
worry about and concern themselves with
and because they do that if they do
their job well the rest of us don't
really have to worry about it because it
sort of just happens when we get access
to this network and it just works that
works work okay anyway so the first
thing we're gonna think about is just
these three terms and we're gonna try
and define them okay so let's start with
your network resources when you hear the
word resources normally commerce that
comes to mind
fosters good raw material such as coal
oil natural gas so we're talking I like
fossil fuels that kind of thing what is
it about those things that makes them a
resource resource why do we call them
resources good right so people like this
stuff you can do stuff when you've got
resources right but you know raw
materials is not the only kinds of
resources there are what other kinds of
resource owner sorry I didn't catch
water okay all right still still raw
materials I'm thinking I'm not so much
physical things that I can like burn or
boil them you know do stuff with yeah
Jack thank you okay so you know for
instance any large company will have a
whole department called HR right which
is about humans and us in our ability to
do things right being resources which
again they're useful it can do things
with okay alright so they're sort of
like the main categories therefore on a
network what might the resources be what
are the things that are on a network
which are which is just what you can do
things salient okay let's start doing
some broad brush
I'm gonna say data yes but let's try to
be a little more specific you can get
data in a system without it being a
network right ladies daughter everywhere
and in kind of system and we talked
about let's see systems then systems
that communicate and communication
systems right and even the most basic
kind of system that has no ability to
communicate that's got data in it that's
useful yes so can we be a little more
specific to Newark what kind of data
might you get on a network that's you
know very useful yeah infinite okay
we're still we go after the same kind of
ID here it was relevant or meaningful
right that makes it information but what
kind of information can you get on a
network that you can't get otherwise
okay so what are we getting at here we
can get other people's data for
information right and when we say other
people's we don't mean our you know
you're prying eyes are getting into
something you're not meant to but for
instance if you want to share things
with people right you need to be on a
network to do that and that's how you
guys all do your presentation and I can
view your data your presentation just up
here because we reside on the same
network okay so data okay when you think
about what makes up a system you've got
data
and then you've got fog where data
that's a beginning we've got hardware
that's another big heading and then we
have what's the third one
okay now what I'd like you guys to do
for a minute is to braise them for
yourself we've been talking about this
kind of thing if we had say a file
server then there will be kinds of data
accessible on the network which are
resources for you okay I like you guys
to get together in some groups women and
have a think okay what hardware might be
connected to a network this is one
example a high drive right that will
become a resource for everyone what
kinds of things do we tend to access
through networks and what about software
what kind of special software would be
we'll through a network which becomes a
resource that everyone can use
okay so I'll give you guys a couple
minutes have a think about that and then
we'll come back together